comme toutes les vidéos de cette chaîne
je vous précise que cette vidéo n'est ni
monétiser ni financer si ce n'est par
des types heures que je remercie
vivement
mais dont je ne suis pas financièrement
dépendants l'objectif n'est absolument
pas de faire des vues ou le buzz ce à
quoi j'aspire à travers cette vidéo
c'est avant tout à apporter une
contribution que j'espère assez
robustement bénéfique pour le bien de
l'humanité en insistant en particulier
sur la nécessité de raisonner de manière
probabiliste sur des enjeux délicats
comme le coronavirus dont la
particularité est d'être plein
d'incertitudes puisque on manque de
données fiables et de recul
j'ajoute aussi que lui a énormément de
relecture donc l'algorithme que j'ai
utilisée pour faire cette vidéo c'est
que j'ai fait un premier jeu les
partager à une vingtaine de personnes
des vulgarisateurs scientifiques des
scientifiques des gens qui sont un peu
plus en domaine aussi et en point qu'il
est ressorti c'est qu'ils sont que
globalement la plupart des gens trouvent
que cette vidéo est assez robustement
bénéfique mais il ya aussi eu beaucoup
de désaccords entre différents reviewer
sur la meilleure façon de communiquer
autour de ce sujet malheureusement
c'était un possible d'agréger les
préférences de tous les reviewer g en
particulier donner moins d'importance à
des remarques qui me semblait manquer de
nuance épistémique et en particulier
probabiliste mais je reconnais
volontiers que les décisions que j'ai
prises ne sont peut-être pas clairement
robustement bénéfique je tiens
d'ailleurs à dire un énorme merci à tous
mes reviewer qui ont pris de leur temps
pour rendre cette vidéo beaucoup plus
robuste mans bénéfique
clairement cette vidéo est largement
améliorable étant donné aussi toutes les
contraintes que j'ai en ce moment en
plus en termes de temps et en terme de
voyages je n'ai pas forcément eu le
temps de faire toute la recherche
biographique nécessaire et tout le
travail avec toutes les précautions qui
on est et désirable cette vidéo est très
imparfaite et j'en suis très désolé mais
non moins j'espère qu'elle est plutôt
bénéfique et qu'elle va plutôt dans le
bon sens alors le coronavirus il ya un
an de discussions à ce sujet et il ya un
débat qui est assez intéressant autour
de débats tant mieux qui et quelle est
la meilleure façon de communiquer autour
du cou aux navires us notamment sachant
que
il y à la fois pas un truc complètement
catastrophique c'est pas l'apocalypse
zombie
tout le monde ne va pas mourir a priori
être très probablement néanmoins il ya
quand même un sérieux risque que
beaucoup beaucoup de gens soient
affectés par cette
cette maladie est que potentiellement
beaucoup de équilibre outrancièrement
beaucoup de victimes de cette maladie
sur le long terme surtout si on ne s'y
prépare pas assez bien et si on ne prend
pas suffisamment de mesures de
prévention du coup savoir comment bien
communiquer autour du cou rona virus
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
compliqué et souvent on s'arrête pas
malade et ressenti ou à des phrases du
genre il faut être plus alarmistes où il
faut être moins alarmiste et comme tout
ça est pas trés quantifier en fait ça
rend les débats un peu flou en fait ça
se trouve on est d'accord sur le bon
degré d'alarmisme à avoir mais comme on
utilise des mots un peu floue et qu'on
n'a pas avec nous on a du mal à comparer
nous est cher le respectifs de à quel
point faut être alarmiste bah ça peut
mener à des débats qui sont pas très
utiles lorsqu'il très important à voir
c'est que on a énormément de données
parcellaires et que c'est difficile
d'avoir accès à des données extrêmement
fiable pour la simple et bonne raison
que c'est très très difficile de
collecter des données fiables à la fois
parce que pas forcément les outils pour
et puis qu'on a une poignée d outils de
dépistage et coûte très très cher et en
plus de ça il faut
techniquement également des pistes et
l'ensemble de la population du monde ce
qui est complètement irréaliste
du coup on est obligé de se contenter de
données partielles qui sont qui ont
plein de défauts qui ont plein de biais
de sélection qui ont plein de biais de
de reporting de la manière dont ce été
rapporté et du coup il faut essayer de
prendre tout ça en compte quand on
analyse les données et c'est absolument
pas se fier directement aux données en
particulier ce qui est très important
c'est de rajouter une incertitude
épistémique sur ces données
c'est pas parce qu'il y a à l'heure
actuelle de 423k recensés en france
d'après la page wikipédia je suis en
train de filmer ça le vendredi 6 mars
sur un sans doute évoluer quand la vidéo
sera sorti lundi
mais les données sont telles qu'elles
sont ça veut pas dire qu'il ya 83 cas en
france
probablement pas du tout mais du coup
quel est le nombre de cas qui en france
il est indispensable d'avoir un langage
probabiliste pour parler de ça et pour
dans un premier temps dans cette vidéo
on va s'intéresser avec la prorité que j
ai le quoran un virus l'a maintenant
mais la question vraiment intéressante
et pertinente
c'est plus de savoir quelle est la
probabilité que j'ai le couronne à virus
dans l'avenir est également qu'elle a
profité que les gens que je connais ce
mes proches mais également toute la
population mondiale aura le couronne à
l'heureuse quelle sera la proportion de
gens qui risque d'être malade quelles
sont les meilleures façons de ralentir
cette progression du coronavirus l'otan
qu'on développe les vaccins est tout ce
qu'il faut et du coup quand on réfléchit
tout ça il semble indispensable d'avoir
un raisonnement beaucoup plus
probabiliste qui met plein de marqueurs
d'incertitude en particulier on va
insister un peu plus tard dans cette
vidéo sur le fait qu' il ya une
incertitude additionnel à avoir à tout
plein d'échelon et c'est pas parce que
la probabilité que j'ai le courant
n'avait reçu aujourd'hui est faible que
je venais à pas à m'en soucier du tout
alors vu que je m'attends à ce que
certains laissent un commentaire on
quitte la vidéo avant d'avoir tout
visionnés je vous propose un petit
résumé des résultats des calculs à la
louche que je vais effectuer ici en gros
noms selon mes calculs jeune et très
probablement pas le coronavirus
aujourd'hui et même si je l'avais il ne
serait très probablement pas mortelle
pour moi et j'ai même envie de rajouter
que ces estimations sont très robustes
cependant la croissance du corona virus
étant exponentielle en l'absence
d'intervention de prévention
il semble y avoir une probabilité non
négligeable et peut-être même grande que
je la contractent d'ici un mois ou deux
et surtout que mes proches le contracte
or mes proches surtout s'ils sont plus
âgés sont bien plus à risque que moi par
ailleurs une contamination rapide du
coronavirus pourrait causer toute sorte
de dysfonctionnements dans nos sociétés
comme une crise financière avec des
risques de licenciements ou de manque
d'approvisionnement ainsi que
potentiellement une surcharge
problématique des hôpitaux
encore une fois ces risques semblent
importants en l'absence d'intervention
même si l'estimation que j'en fais ici
et pour le coup moins robustes
et il faut s'attendre à ce que des
analyses légèrement différente
potentiellement plus valides que la
mienne conduisent à des conclusions un
peu différente
néanmoins la simple probabilité non
négligeable que le coronavirus finissent
par toucher une proportion non
négligeable de la population mondiale
semble être une préoccupation importante
or il semble que de nombreuses
interventions allant de se laver les
mains à cesser de serrer la main des
autres en passant par travail et si
possible à distance et annuler les
événements de grande ampleur ces
interventions semble réduire
significativement la propagation du
coronavirus il semble alors
potentiellement très bénéfique de suivre
ces recommandations et ce peut-être même
davantage en tant qu'acte de solidarité
sociale qu en tant qu actes égoïstes
donc passons à la question principale de
cette vidéo à savoir quelle est la
probabilité que j'ai le coronavirus
aujourd'hui alors moi j'habite en suisse
à lausanne
et je pense qu'on peut commencer par un
premier échantillon qui est le nombre de
cas recensés en tout cas d'après la page
wikipédia qui est je pense une des
sources les plus fiables qu'il ya à
l'heure actuelle à ce sujet quel est le
nombre de cas rapportés en suisse alors
certains sont peut-être surpris que je
m'appuie sur wikipédia en fait l'équipe
et dia l'uimm s'appuie sur un autre site
web qui lui m'a été directement
recommandé par différents biologistes en
qui j'ai confiance
alors bien sûr pour les spécialistes du
domaine il existe du coût des ressources
qui sont meilleures que celles de
wikipedia en l'occurrence aussi bien
mais si ce n'est pas votre domaine et
pour le coup là on n'est pas du tout
dans mon domaine or wikipedia me semble
être un excellent point de départ est
d'ailleurs de façon assez générale je me
suis permis de voler une idée d'hygiène
mentale que je trouve excellente qui
consiste à se forcer à lire wikipédia
juste après avoir été exposé un contenu
controversé sous forme de tweet ou
d'articles de journal est bien le nombre
de cas recensés en suisse en ce vendredi
6 mars c'est 110 9 d'après la page
wikipedia et parmi ces 119 il ya eu un
mort d'après la page wikipédia ok mais
ça c'est le cas au sein c'est alors les
bonnes raisons de penser que en suisse
vu que
il ya beaucoup de moyens en suisse que
le dépistage est peut-être meilleure
qu'ailleurs dans le monde et que ce
n'est peut-être pas trop loin de ça mais
il ya toujours ce problème qui est que
dans pour le coronavirus il ya une phase
on va dire à peu près de deux semaines
de 14 joueurs durant laquelle il n'y a
aucun symptôme et du coup il ya priori
aucune raison de d'essayer de ceux
d'être dépisté qu'il n'y a pas de
motivation a essayé de se tester et du
coup ce qu'on peut imaginer que c'est
que en gros les 119 cas correspondent à
tous ceux qui a eu lieu avant deux
semaines donc c'est l'essai semble pas
vrai mais c'est une estimation que je
vais faire un peu à la louche pour
essayer d'imaginer quel est le nombre de
cas qu'il a effectivement en suisse en
prenant compte ceux qui n'ont pas suivi
un peu de tests
du coup la question qui se pose
maintenant pour savoir quel est le
nombre de cas en suisse
à l'heure actuelle c'est d'essayer de
jeu d'imaginer sachant qu'il ya eu 119
il ya deux semaines combien il devrait y
en avoir aujourd'hui
façon approximative quoi supposer que
les 119 cas si c'est quelqu'un était
malade
avant il y a deux semaines alors très
probablement il lui a déjà eu ces
symptômes et du coup très probablement
il a suivi un test et du coup
probablement il a été recensé
il ya plein de bémol à mettre donc tous
à ccc vraiment approximatif c'est plus à
la louche
d'ailleurs pour bien montrer que c'est à
la louche je remplaçais le 119 par des
ordres de grandeur ce que vous
intéresser si ces ordres de grandeur
donc on va regarder que c'est on va
concerner que c'est environ 100
personnes
donc là aussi c'est environ deux
semaines et pour essayer d'estimer du
coup le nombre de cas qu'il ya
aujourd'hui ce que je vous propose c'est
de regarder la progression du
coronavirus en l'espace de deux semaines
combien il y à de nouveaux cas et ça on
a des graves par rapport à ça notamment
il ya un grave de
qui a été partagé en parts fugue ou en
droit que kiki qui regarde le nombre de
cas est en gros ça suit une courbe
vraiment exponentielle
très proche de l'expansion va dire donc
ça c'est le nombre de cas en fonction du
temps et en particulier si on les garde
l'échelle logarithmique donc qu'est-ce
que c'est très difficile d'analyser
directement une courbe exponentielle
comme ça est-ce qu'on peut regarder
c'est le log du nombre de cas et si on
regarde le nom de l'ocs du nombre de cas
au cours du temps l'aca suis bon c'est
pas tout à fait une droite donc le
nombre de cas hors chine ça ressemble
plus à ça et si on regarde un peu des
chiffres donc au 1er mars il y avait à
peu près dix mille cas je veux dire
quelque chose qui est autour du 1er
février en fait que c'est un peu avant
le 1er février mon va tout tout en vous
dire toi sont tous être très
approximatif il y avait à peu près à peu
près 100 cas donc ça ce que ça montre
c'est que le nombre de cas a été hué un
x 100 et ça ça veut dire qu on va
prendre la baseline qu'on va dire que ça
fait x 10 en deux semaines ça c'est un
peu la louche
donc si ça fait x 10 en deux semaines et
qu'il y avait 100 cas donc il y a deux
semaines
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui ça fait x 10
nous qui a environ 1000 cas aujourd'hui
j'espère que ça va tourner donc ça c'est
une estimation
il ya plein d'incertitudes probablement
mais là c'est encore à la louche que je
vais faire mais l'incertitude je la fais
un peu foi de à peu près je pense que
c'est c'est 1000 cas on va dire entre
500 et 2000 cas en suisse avec un
intervalle de crédence raisonnable pas
non plus énorme
ils ont donc 80% 80 80 % de crédence
qu'il ya entre 500 et 2015 donc en tout
cas on va travailler à peu près avec
1000 donc maintenant 6ème il cas en
suisse
quel est le pourcentage de la population
en suisse qui est affecté donc en suisse
et la population suisse en suisse il y a
huit millions d'habitants
d'habitants et là encore je vais
arrondir façon être au moins un facteur
de près donc là je veux dire que ça peu
près 10 millions comme ça les
modifications seront faciles donc s'il y
a mille cas sur 10 millions donc un sur
dix millions donc ça fait du coup un sur
dix milles sur 10000 donc c'est égal à
[Musique]
10% 0 01 % donc à 0,01 pour cent d'après
mes estimations de la population suisse
qui a affecté par le corona virus alors
ceci dit une grosse partie de la suisse
vit dans des endroits assez reculée et
moi j'habite à lausanne opus royal
universitaire le pfl qui est très
internationale et sur lesquelles il ya
beaucoup de mouvement et j'ai été à des
événements
où il y as facile 30 40 50 personnes
donc je pense être dans une partie
beaucoup plus exposés que la plupart des
suisses du coup j'estimerai cela plus à
quelque chose de tête 5 à 10 fois plus
on va dire donc si wes styles mais ça a
vraiment à la louche a pour moi
du coup la probabilité que j'ai le corps
en avait eu virus je dirais que c'est à
peu près à 0,1 pour cent ouais c'est
assez conservateur dirais que c'est
entre plus entre disons 0,0 disons que
c'est plus entre 0,01 pour cent et diouf
0,2 pour cent quelque chose comme ça si
je suis un conservateur
mais du coup la probabilité que j'ai le
coronavirus a priori c'est c'est quelque
chose d'assez faible de l'ordre de 0,1
pour cent donc a priori ça ça va ça va
pour moi selon ce calcul ce risque est
faible pour moi par ailleurs pour un
individu tirer au hasard dans la
population française
il est probable que le risque pour lui
soient similaires ou me rends vu que la
situation en france est en train de
devenir assez similaire à la situation
en suisse
en tout cas en première approximation
cependant ce n'est pas nécessairement le
cas pour vous individuellement
vu que vous n'êtes pas un individu tirer
au hasard dans la population française
en particulier votre risque pourrait
être différent notamment si vous avez eu
plus de risques d'exposition aux
coronavirus que moi souvenez-vous qu'un
bayésiens doit essayer de prendre en
compte toutes les données à sa
disposition et vous avez des données
vous concernant
qui ne sont pas les mêmes que les
données que j'ai me concernant ou que
les données que j'ai concernant un
individu tirer au hasard dans la
population française
et même si vous avez un plus grand
risque d'exposition coronavirus surtout
ne paniquez pas posé les calculs fait
des estimations mesure et l'incertitude
ensuite prenez décisions éclairées qui
conviennent prenons par exemple le cas
d'un individu qui aurait les symptômes
aujourd'hui pour connaître la
probabilité qu'il est le coronavirus
sachant qu'il est les symptômes
je vous invite à faire le calcul
bayésiens correspondant la principale
alternative ici est le fait d'avoir une
grippe
oui mais a priori la grippe touche
quelques pour cent de la population soit
10 à 100 fois plus que notre estimation
pour le co
un virus donc la grippe est a priori 10
à 100 fois plus probable que le
coronavirus les symptômes sont toutefois
les mêmes pour la grippe et le
coronavirus ne favorise pas une
hypothèse vis-à-vis de l'autre donc à
postériori aussi sachant les symptômes
la grippe demeure 10 à 100 fois plus
probable que le coronavirus la
probabilité d'avoir le coronavirus
sachant les symptômes est alors de
quelques pour cent seulement noté que
ces approximations très approximative
sont d'ailleurs confirmées par les
chiffres des autorités suisses ou
aujourd'hui le 8 mars midi il y avait 2
181 cas confirmés pour plus de 4000
personnes testées négatives
cependant j'insiste sur le fait que la
situation risque fortement d'évoluer
puisque la propagation du coronavirus
risque d'être bien plus importante que
celle du virus de la grippe
donc ça c'est faible c'est probablement
assez négligeable surtout que bon on
peut estimer que la probabilité que je
meure du coronavirus sachant que j'ai le
coronavirus donc les chiffres sont
quelques pourcents pour la population
générale mais pour quelqu'un de mon âge
mais moi j'ai pas de problème de santé
particulier
du coup il a profité que je meurs de
cours en algérie c est vraiment faible
je pense qu'elle est de 0,1 pour cent
souhaitent même nous perdons
du coup la priorité que je meure du
corona virus à cause du fait que je
l'aide aisé aujourd'hui fait elle est
vraiment négligeable surtout si on
compare ça à la priorité que j'ai un
accident de la route ou quelque chose
comme ça du coup il semble que je n'ai
vraiment pas intérêt à me soucier outre
mesure du coronavirus pour moi cependant
aujourd'hui
cependant les choses risquent de ne pas
mal évoluer dans les semaines à venir
donc évidemment on a vu que ça faisait
foi disent toutes les deux semaines
et du coup en fait assez rapidement
la probabilité que j'ai le corona virus
va pas mal augmenté
du coup dans un mois déjà si on projette
un peu le modèle ça serait à 10,1 fois
cent par rapport à ce que j'ai
aujourd'hui
et là du coup on passerait beaucoup plus
proches d'eux
en plus donc plus qu'un pour cent voire
même
quelque chose de l'ordre de 10% d'autant
que l'âge est en voyage prévu en paris
pour donner une conférence à centrale
supélec du coup si je regarde à la fin
du mois du coup fin mars la proriété que
j'ai le corps ne reviendra largement
beaucoup moins négligeable et si je
regarde
dans deux mois la priorité que j'ai eu
le corps à un virus ce sera probablement
autour de 50% alors il faut que
j'insiste beaucoup sur un point cette
projection est la prédiction d'un modèle
simplifié qui s'appuie sur des données
très partielle des estimations très
grossière et sur l'hypothèse selon
laquelle il n'y aura pas ou peu de
mesures de prévention ou qu'elles ne
seront pas ou peu respectée mais aussi
avec l'hypothèse selon laquelle le virus
restera tel qu'il est et qu'il ne me
fera pas trop il en fait énormément
d'incertitudes vis-à-vis de cette
projection en fonction des variantes du
modèle qu'on considère des hypothèses
alternatives qu'on envisage et surtout d
estimation grossière que l'on fait ne
vous arrêtez surtout pas à ce chiffre
l'ordre de grandeur doit être prise en
compte mais il doit être prise en compte
avec de grosses pincettes
en fait un bond bayésiens nous faut
absolument mettre régulièrement à jour
cette prédiction fur et à mesure que de
nouvelles données seront collectées et
partagées
il est tout à fait possible que cette
estimation chute à 1% notamment si des
mesures de prévention efficaces sont
proposés et appliqué mais il est aussi
possible que suite à des nouvelles
données il monte au delà de 50 % pensez
à constamment faire danser vos curseur
de turing souvenez vous l'apprentissage
est une danse pas un écrit forgée dans
le marbre
c'est possible aussi que le virus ne
mute
enfin c'est même très probable que le
virus contient mythes et des
informations que j'avais refait pas
obligé sur la virologue donc gens c'est
très peu très peu de choses mais de ce
que j'ai cru comprendre ce qui est assez
probable c'est que le virus mute en
étant moins agressif à ce possible que
ce soit plus le contagieux du coup c'est
possible qu'on en arrive à grande
fraction de la population touchée mais
c'est aussi possible que ce soit moins
mortel fait c'est un des scénarios
possibles mais peut-être le plus
probable mais je pense que c'est
important de ne pas écarter complètement
la possibilité que si une grande
proportion de la population est touchée
vas-y les mutations qui soit
du virus qui soit vraiment dangereuses
ou problématiques faudra voir comment ça
va évoluer à ce que ce sera davantage
contenu que ça ne l'est aujourd'hui
ou est-ce que ça va encore davantage se
diffuser ça ça dépend dans quel point il
y ait des mesures de prévention
notamment cité des grands événements
comme le marathon de paris qui sont
annulés
et c'est le cas ça devrait réduire la
capacité de propagation du virus
une petite remarque par rapport à cela
la manière dont le virus a été contenue
en chine suggèrent fortement que les
mesures de prévention sont très
efficaces pour réduire significativement
la propagation du virus puisque de façon
remarquable la propagation du virus a
non seulement été freinée mais même
contenu en chine
c'est pour cela que les recommandations
comme se laver les mains ne pas se
serrer les mains tousser dans son coude
plutôt que dans sa main ne pas
participer à des événements plein de
monde s'éloigner des foules travailler
de chez soi par faire une petite
retraite en campagne peuvent être très
efficaces pour réduire la propagation du
virus
voilà qui peut être très utile notamment
pour soulager la probable surcharge des
hôpitaux à venir et ainsi permettre à
chacune des victimes du coronavirus être
mieux prises en charge
souvenez-vous le problème du coronavirus
n'est pas uniquement un problème
individuel c'est peut-être même
davantage un problème collectif et en
particulier il convient de protéger ceux
qui sont potentiellement les plus
vulnérables vous qui regardez cette
vidéo n'allait probablement pas mourir
je dirais même qu à titre individuel
vous n'allez probablement même pas
souffrir du coronavirus nul besoin de
trop vous en soucier pour vous même
surtout à l'heure actuelle cependant
vous pouvez vous dire que si jamais vous
transmettez le coronavirus à 10
personnes
l'une d'elles risque d'en souffrir et si
vous le transmettez à 100 personnes
vous avez une probabilité importante de
tuer indirectement quelqu'un du coup en
suivant les recommandations de
prévention et en les encourageant à
linverse vous pouvez indirectement
sauver des vies prendre des mesures
préventives
c'est avant tout effectuer une action
altruiste peu coûteuse et qui est sans
doute même relativement efficace
aujourd'hui par rapport à d'autres
actions altruistes que vous pourriez
avoir en tête
donc ça c'est un peu ce qu'indique cette
analyse brésilienne très très
approximative très
13e ristic faut pas ultra trop s'y fier
et il ya plein de choses qui peuvent
arriver peut-être que les prédictions
que je fais ici sont pas du tout sont
peut-être à côté de la plaque même
peut-être carrément à côté de la plaque
du coup vaut mieux rester vigilant
essayer d'avoir accès à des meilleures
données à chaque fois suivre les
conseils des experts et en particulier
faire attention à pas trop se fier à
notre intuition et c'est possible aussi
cherché à quantifier autant que possible
et prendre en compte l'incertitude sur
les chiffres je pense que tout ça c'est
important
je mets en descriptions quelques liens
que je trouve très intéressant sur le
degré de prudence adéquat avoir
vis-à-vis du coronavirus parce que si on
regarde si on projette le nombre de
morts qui pourrait avoir à cause du
courneau un virus même si c'est 0,1 pour
cent aujourd'hui apparence elle ça tu es
dehors de quelques pourcents de 2 3 %
des gens infectés par le corona gruss
s'il coronavirus se propager atteint
moitié de la population mondiale a un ou
deux pourcent de morts de moitié de la
population mondiale ça fait ça fait
quand même beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
morts et donc il semble vraiment y avoir
lieu de se préoccuper d'accélérer la
recherche autour de tout ça de mieux
financer toutes ces structures et tout
ce qui est prévention de prendre soin de
l'hygiène et tout ça mais je pense qu'il
ya vraiment vraiment lieu de
de bien se préparer d'encourager chacun
à bien se préparer aux couronnes un
virus même si c'est pas du tout
l'apocalypse et qu'il faut pas paniquer
outre mesure voilà c'est un peu
l'impression que j'ai à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui avec les données que j'ai
aujourd'hui et la lecture que j'ai eus
j'ai pas eu énormément de lecture pour
être honnête j'ai juste suivi
essentiellement des sources en qui j'ai
confiance comme le world forum national
wikipédia et quelques ressources
commandes de virologues d'experts du
domaine
je pense que c'est même mieux d'avoir
uniquement l'information qui vient de
d'entités dont on a confiance et ne pas
être trop pollué par
toutes sortes d'informations de moindre
qualité même si elles sont justes la
manière dont s'est extrait peut conduire
à des mets compréhension et à linverse
en tant que communicateur
je pense que c'est très important pour
ce genre de cas de faire très attention
à la manière dont on communique parce
que c'est très subtil il faut pas
l'armée faux faux faux faux faux pas qui
de panique il n'y a pas lieu mais faut
vraiment qu'on s'y prépare parce que il
ya un risque potentiel et
potentiellement peut potentiellement je
pense que c'est encore possible
aujourd'hui avoir des millions de morts
à cause du poireau navires us à la fin
de l'année ben faut je pense qu'il faut
rester prudent et encourager autant que
possible la recherche les mots mais les
mesures de prévention et le dépistage
les les petites mesures pour juste
freiner la propagation du us puisque
plus on arrive à freiner la pop up
propagation du virus
puis on aura le temps ensuite de s'armer
pour combattre ce virus et diminuer les
effets secondaires néfastes de ces virus
parce qu'il faut faire attention un peu
à la sécurité dans ce genre de
discussions et pas juste y aller avec le
cas le plus probable la probablement je
vais pas du tout levier le coronavirus
même je pense que c'est ça reste assez
probable que je n'ai jamais le cours
d'un virus mais il faut pas y aller avec
le truc le plus probable je pense qu'en
termes de sécurité c'est important
d'envisager tous les scénarios possibles
je vous invite à continuer à vous
informer à faire attention à tout ça et
surtout essayer de bien communiquer
c'est vraiment pas facile autour du
coronavirus